the theme of corporate greed isn't
exactly new ground in science fiction or
even in Star Wars but and or does do
something pretty unique with the concept
in the form of a new planet the latest
live-action Star Wars TV show and or is
set five years before the events of Star
Wars A New Hope the series follows
Cassian Andor a mercenary who becomes a
rookie member of the fledgling Rebel
Alliance over the course of the series
it'll fill in the gaps in the story that
culminate with and or stealing the plans
to the Death Star in Rogue one a Star
Wars story while shows like the
Mandalorian and Obi-Wan Kenobi have
brought fans back to familiar Star Wars
locales and or will bring viewers to a
relatively unfamiliar corner of the Star
Wars Galaxy only one of the four major
planets on the show The Imperial capital
Coruscant has been featured in Star Wars
movies and TV shows before the other
three panari ferrics and morlana one are
all brand new Creations according to
Empire online the sets for Andor were
built entirely with practical effects
instead of the volume video wall Disney
is used to film recent Star Wars
projects showrunner Tony Gilroy said
creating these worlds felt like playing
God each of these planets has unique
specific lived-in feel qunari is a lush
tropical world where people live in
small tribes and don't speak basic the
Star Wars equivalent of English it's
relatively Untouched by the Empire
there's not a lot about qunari sir it's
fairly obscure pharynx is a desert
Planet home to countless crashed
Starships this has led to an economy
based entirely on Salvage so that one
will probably at least feel familiar to
Star Wars fans then there's more Lana
one which feels unlike any other planet
in Star Wars up to now it's a mining
Planet ruled by the pre-ox morlana
corporation while pre-ox morlana does
report to the Galactic Empire it's an
entity unto itself it has its own
security force that can investigate
crimes and make arrests all of which
will come into play as the series goes
on pre-ox morlana controls nearly every
aspect of life on morlano one not just
the government it's citizens are also
its workers in this way it resembles the
mining towns in the American old west
where a single company controlled
everything naturally this leads to
oppressive conditions the kind that
would drive someone to join a rebellion
morlano one is the first planet seen in
actor in the opening scenes Cassian goes
into a more Lana one brothel in search
of his sister only to run afoul of two
pre-ox morlana security officers
nicknamed corpos employees are required
to present their ideas upon requests
he's forced to kill them this puts
pre-ox murlana Deputy inspector Cyril
Karn on andors trail and soon Karn
becomes obsessed with hunting and or
down science fiction is full of massive
corporations that are as powerful as
governments if not more so like Weyland
yutani from Alien the Tyrell Corporation
from Blade Runner or arasaka from
cyberpunk 2077. it's also full of
planets that are governed by one and
only one government like Gallifrey from
Doctor Who or Krypton in Man of Steel
however a planet that's ruled by a
corporation is rare both in Star Wars
and in science fiction in general the
nearest equivalent in Star Wars comes
from the Legends timeline which Disney
removed from the Canon when it purchased
lucasfilm in Legends the corporate
sector is a region in the outer rim
governed by a series of Corporations
under the sway of the Galactic Empire
it's the setting of The Han Solo
Adventures novel Trilogy that was
published in the early 1990s as well as
the accompanying role-playing game Han
Solo and the corporate sector Source
book but given that these books are
three decades old and no longer Canon
they're not much of a guide when it
comes to morlano 1. plenty of Star Wars
planets are governed by oppressive
regimes but this is a case where the
government is motivated by profit rather
than other forms of power
foreign